we're going to talk about kidney
dialysis and I know that right now
you're probably getting ready to push
the button on your TV remote marks dear
God literally anything else but I
promise you this is worth listening to
because dialysis if not something
everybody understands I just listened to
one patient describe a conversation that
she had with a neighbor I have a lady
next door to me now she said to me where
do you go three days a week
she knew the three days a week I said
why are you writing a book of mystery I
said I go to dialysis she said oh you
were drunk I thought you said you didn't
drink I said if you don't get out of my
face you will need a doctor if I was her
neighbor
I would not with that lady what I
would do is get out of her face go home
Google what dialysis is just to cool
down the temperature in that
relationship and here is the answer to
that dialysis is basically where a
machine acts as your kidneys by taking
blood out of your body cleaning it and
then returning it to you think of it as
a Brita pitcher for your blood which yes
is more disgusting than I need you to
make it sound dialysis can be a truly
exhausting process you're typically
sitting in a chair physically attached
to a machine for three four-hour
sessions a week and Americans have been
an increasing risk of needing it because
chronic kidney disease is the ninth
leading cause of death in the United
States and while a lucky few managed to
get transplants for many dialysis is
their only option to stay alive but
interestingly here what America spends
more by some accounts than any other
nation on Dallas's care we have one of
the industrialized world highest
mortality rates so we're spending a most
to essentially get the least we're
basically paying for a fully loaded
Lamborghini and receiving a drunk donkey
on rollerskates this this story the
story of dialysis is an amazing case
study of good intentions being thwarted
by bad incentives poor oversight and
profiteering and one of the key
characters in the stories incredibly
this guy just saved us all
[Music]
[Applause]
now if you are understandably thinking
who is that man doing barefoot
gymnastics to Bob Seger while dressed
like the third saddest way to add a
medieval times well that is the CEO of
divita incorporated a for-profit kidney
dialysis company and I promise we will
get to that man in a moment but first
let me give you a sense of the history
of dialysis in this country because in
the early years of the machines access
to them was so limited one Hospital have
an actual death panel to decide who
would get to use them somebody has got
to decide who shall live and who shall
die two or three were rejected I think I
don't know why either for medical
reasons or psychological reasons or just
didn't have a $30,000
mr. Duff what happened to those who
would turn down oh my god that man does
not sugarcoat things they're dead also
your pet only love you because you feed
it the Tooth Fairy is your father and
30% of babies grow up to be
good day to you sir
now in 1972 though something amazing
happened Richard Nixon yes Richard Nixon
signed a bill into law which said that
the government would pay for dialysis
for anyone who needed it which is really
incredible essentially we have universal
health care in this country for one
organ in the body it's like your kidneys
and only your kidneys are Canadian Oh
Laurie those properties don't mean to
take too much space shop down hurry
that's a good axis and I do not
apologize for now the promise of great
acting so at the time that bill was
parked it only covered around 10,000
patients but four decades later thanks
in part to the rise of diabetes and high
blood pressure nearly half a million
people are undergoing dialysis that's a
46 fold rise 46 fold technically
speaking that is a pug face worth of
folds and as a result and this is true
treating end-stage kidney v's
takes up nearly 1% of the entire federal
budget just think about that for a
second we devote two percent of the
federal budget to the Department of
Education and that's the thing that
helps you know what a percent is and a
vast industry has emerged to accommodate
all these patients that there are around
7,000 outpatient dialysis clinics in the
country today and around 70% are owned
by just too big for profit companies
Fresenius and divita and let me be clear
there are significant issues with both
of them but to understand your system
tonight we're going to focus on debita
their CEO Ken theory is the showboating
musketeer that you saw earlier and he
loves to inspire his employees at
meetings he's also made grand entrances
on a bicycle
he's even ridden in on a horse
and spare a thought for that horse there
that that is by far the most humiliating
credit on its resume and it did used to
do porn so you have to bear that in mind
clearly if a former bain and company
consultant and manage to take the visa
from near bankruptcy to being value
today at thirteen billion dollars he's
even been the subject of an admiring
case study taught at Harvard Business
School
which called his management style
arguably eccentric and you can see why
he calls his company a village his
employees teammates or citizens and as
for himself well he's got his own
special title this is Casey here your
mayor from the Casanova in Colorado yes
you heard right
he calls himself the mayor a title so
ridiculous you may not have noticed he's
standing next to a Falcon that
is the most humiliating thing on that
birds resume and it used to do porn so I
guess at this point at this point we
should probably address the whole weird
must get to hit thing it's an obsession
that apparently stems from that Leonardo
DiCaprio movie the man in the iron mask
which yep we're theory says inspiring to
make a transformative life decision to
take the devika job which is already
insane because this is a ridiculous
movie to choose of the basis for
anything let me give you just a small
taste if we must die
that'll be like this mantra of the one
[Music]
that remains one of the weirdest
decisions in movie making history thanks
the world's biggest heartthrob at the
peak of his popularity agreed to be in
our movie what should we do with him
oh I know let's put him in a weird mask
for cover his whole face and just have
him stand there I guarantee that teenage
girls all across America are going to
have that image on their bedroom wall he
looks even hotter now clearly even close
use company meetings quoting that movie
if we must allies that if you like this
one 400
damn straight have fun good night
[Applause]
cool look you think the shareholders
very techniques have worked a visa
posted nearly eight hundred million
dollars in profit last year but the
experience the patients can be different
Davina runs a pretty lean operation
which the government allows the federal
guidelines don't require clinics to have
a doctor on-site at any given time which
seems a little odd they also require
that only one nurse be present in the
facility and a study has found that
for-profit clinics have about as third
fewer nurses than their nonprofit
competitors and that might explain why
some to be the patient's say they can
feel like they're a product on a factory
line I have Tech's come up to me the old
s enough dialysis you didn't pour on
plenty so it where during my mind to
believe and I'm feeling my full
treatment then I'm supposed to be
getting just because they're behind ya
you can't just speed up dialysis because
you'll be hiding schedule it is a
critical medical procedure not a shower
oh I've only got three minutes so I'm
just watching the important parts hair
armpits and penis cuz it's my little
puppy I'd never forget you but dialysis
workers in California are currently
trying to unionize over issues including
staffing levels and one former divita
nurse of more than a decade who defeated
told us was fired for violating company
policy by asking employees to join a
union at the clinic where he no longer
worked says workers felt constantly
pressured to transition between patients
as fast as possible well when I was
working at de vida the priorities for
transitioning patients was to get them
on dialysis and get the next patient on
as soon as possible and it was all about
numbers you want to get them in get
their dollars is done and get the next
patient on and you would have sometimes
15 maybe 25 minutes to get that next
patient on on machine so you are not
properly disinfecting are doing the
things that you needed to do properly
not properly disinfecting that cannot be
okay
I don't even want to go into a movie
theater that hasn't had enough time to
be cleaned and the worst thing that can
happen to you there is shuffling through
a waist-deep layer of popcorn and dried
sticky cherry coke and a lot Davina will
tell you it's clinics operate to our
high standard of care its patients
aren't rushed they have many happy staff
and customers and they've shown steady
improvement over the years and they'll
even point to the high number of clinics
that have received four and five stars
from the government's rating system but
that actually points to another
oversight issue here because weirdly
those ratings don't reflect things like
government inspection reports for the
clinics because remember that patient
from before we actually pulled her
clinics most recent report which cited
among other things multiple problems
with infection control practices and a
failure to demonstrate overall
responsibility for the governance and
operation of the facility which placed
all patients staff and visitors at risk
of harm and possible death and guess how
many stars it has four stars so that
four star ratings should really come
with a big asterisk which to be fair
just technically constitute a fifth star
congratulations and if it's beginning to
feel like the beta is run like a volume
business well when you listen to Kent
theory that can seem like it's by design
just listen to him addressing business
students at UCLA about what he sees as
his company's role in society I almost
never refer to patients in the entire
thing because it's for me it's not about
the patients it's about the teammates
when you're in health care it is it is
nicer easier whatever in the sense that
you're actually very directly helping
human beings but that's to me that's
just not it if I if I had 1,400 taco
bells and 32,000 people who worked in
them I would I would be doing all the
same stuff yes you have been right he
just said he manages to beta a health
care company like you would a Taco Bell
the exact opposite of a health care
company look Taco Bell has made a shell
entirely out of fried chicken sounds
crazy but is it so when you see the
naked chicken chalupa with the first
shell made entirely out of fried chicken
you might think
really creating delicious you know it's
a pretty safe sign that your product is
awful when your commercial has to assure
people on two separate occasions look we
know we sound mentally ill but trust us
it is food it's actually food I know I
know I look to be fair debater might
tell you that they have to run their
business so lean because the
reimbursement they get from the
government doesn't really cover their
costs but they have been repeatedly
accused of finding innovative ways
around that this was a few years ago the
company was sued over accusations
neither paid kickbacks to doctors for
business the scheme is kind of
complicated but it basically works like
this Davida would pick out doctors and
physicians groups who cared for a large
number of patients who had renal disease
and then it would offer them lucrative
deals to refer patients to their
dialysis clinic okay so that is
obviously not good you want to be sure
that a doctor is referring you to a
clinic because it's the best one for you
not because they have a financial
relationship you should only advocate
for a product that you really believe in
like the world ladders so they don't pay
me to say nice things about their
products people why would they the
ladders speak for themselves
now now to be fair denies wrongdoing but
they did settle that lawsuit for three
hundred and eighty nine million dollars
and remember that because it's about to
become a theme because in 2012 a former
medical director at intubated facility
went public with claims about how the
Vita treated some of the medicine that
it could charge Medicare for for
instance let's say a patient needed a
hundred milligrams of a drug called
Bennifer you could give them say one one
hundred milligram vial or you could do
this with a Vita did set up this one
vial
they gave 50 milligram out of this vial
residual trash 2575 to the trash 25
again 75 to the trash the more vials
divita used the more davido was able to
build the government holy
but is the biggest waste of drugs since
anyone who's done
cocaine in a windstorm although you know
what you know what on the bright side
those pigeons look confident and they
have somehow written screenplays there
you go that's the beauty of cocaine
everywhere that's the beauty now now
again again the Vita strongly denied
wrongdoing and they did so even if they
agreed to pay up to 495 million dollars
to settle that case that in almost half
a billion dollar oops
or as Yankees fans call it an a-rod and
a and a separate case accused them not
so much of throwing extra drugs into the
trash as throwing them into the patients
and that involves something called
Epogen a medication used to raise a
patient's red blood cell count a
whistleblower said that the Vita
personnel referred to it as liquid gold
and with good reason
at one point it accounted for a quarter
of the company's revenue and up to 40%
of its earnings although it was later
discovered but at the higher dosage
levels that the Vita was using there was
no solid evidence that Epogen made
people feel better improved survival or
have any clinical benefit at all which
is incidentally also the new tagline for
this television show and it seems fair
it seems harsh but increasingly fair and
and I think you know what is coming now
the Vita denied any wrongdoing and
settled that lawsuit for fifty five
million dollars and to beat or say do
they keep settling cases because they
can't afford to get shut out from
Medicare but the fact remains just the
three cases I have mentioned in the last
five years have resulted them paying out
nearly a billion dollars in settlements
and that doesn't exactly give you
confidence in their product if the
fleshlight company paid a billion
dollars in settlement you would do what
everyone else does and you would a
microwave cantaloupe yep 30 seconds on
defrost trust me 30 seconds 30 seconds
no more but no less 30 seconds is this
lease block ding business time but
forget that what was the point the point
is here is where we get to the final and
possibly the hardest part of this story
because the fact is no matter what
to decay you get the longer you are on
dialysis the worse things look for you
people who are on dialysis how long are
they going to laugh right so the
statistics are that one year after being
on dialysis your death rate or is 25% by
five years it's 65 percent and numbers
like that are why if you are at all
eligible to get a kidney transplant
you absolutely should get one it can
double or even triple your survival rate
and yet the government's main
requirement for dialysis clinics in
educating patients about transplants is
that they simply check a box indicating
that they've done so and multiple
studies of the industry have questioned
the quality of some clinics education
thousands of kidney patients in the
United States start dialysis without
first being told about kidney
transplants or that the procedure would
be cheaper and lead the longer live the
newspaper reviewed records from the
United States renal data system and they
found that some patients spent five
years on dialysis before being put on
the kidney transplant list it's true
some clinics are leaving out information
that people really should know and
information on transplants at a dialysis
clinic is a bit like information about
the number of Farex you own while you're
on a tinder date you need to disclose
that right up front so that people
don't make a huge mistake you have to do
that you have to do that it's not right
you disclose that you let them know
what's wrong with you and look debated
disputes that those studies reflect
their practices saying that then those
recent internal figures show them
outperforming their competitors in
percentage of patients receiving a
transplant although for what it is worth
we wanted to get a glimpse of what their
education might look like and honestly
it wasn't great divita offers kidney
smart classes basically orientation for
pre dialysis patients and they're open
to the public so we sent four staffers
to classes at four different clinics
here in New York and they were all
struck by how little emphasis was placed
on the benefits of transplants and that
they were often presented as an
equivalent choice to dialysis in fact
here is what happened when one staffer
asked specifically about what
the people who came to that clinic saw
transplants it's a choice it's actually
a choice you don't have to do a
transplant I've had patients that
decided to no I don't want that
and even if you're if you don't have a
doughnut you go on that transplant list
and when they do call you of course you
have the right to say no I don't think
so I don't want it now you never know
things things happen I mean this is a
family night I know I say this and it
sounds crazy but I've had patients and I
don't think I want to leave so I won't
take the transplant any state this is
there this is their community okay okay
suggesting that the cozy atmosphere of a
DeVito dialysis center is a valid reason
to turn down a kidney transplant
if the moral equivalence of watching
someone tread water in the middle of the
ocean and not encouraging him to take a
rope are you sure are you sure
the ocean isn't your community are you
sure you want the people have turned
this rock down before you know there's
no bad decision here and look we focused
on Tavita because they have the most
patients and Kent Theory dresses like an
idiot all the time but a lot of the
problems we've seen run throughout the
for-profit dialysis industry including
their main competitor Fresenius who just
last year agreed to a two hundred and
fifty million dollar settlement for
thousands of lawsuits claiming that the
company's products had cause heart
problems and deaths claims that they
deny because you know of course they do
so here's the thing I know that all of
this has been very complicated but there
are actually a few key lessons here
first we need to make sure that dialysis
clinics have better oversight and we
need to create better incentives for
transplants and for treating kidney
disease earlier to keep patients out of
dialysis in the first place and there
are things that everyone can do to
combat the kidney shortage actually
amazing people can donate one of their
own kidneys while they're still alive
and if you are someone considerably
doing that holy you're an amazing
human being feel free to go to give and
live us for more information on that and
for the rest of us complete
we should at least at the very least be
organ donors when we die because organs
can go to waste as families hesitate to
give approval when a loved one died so
please please make sure that your family
knows that you want to be a donor and
once you've done that maybe tweet out
hashtag when I die please take my
kidneys because if nothing else it will
really with Twitter's trending
topics tomorrow but where here's the
thing this country did a truly amazing
thing Richard Nixon did a truly really
well history has changed Richard Nixon
is a truly amazing thing he said we
should take care of people with kidney
disease and we did it and we should keep
doing it but but we could do it a lot
better the care of America's kidneys is
way too important to be treated like a
fast food experience which actually
reminds me there is another victim of
this story and that is Taco Bell yes
that's right Taco Bell is owed an
apology and that sentence has never
before made sense in the English
language but Taco Bell I am truly sorry
that a middle-aged musketeer dragged you
into this and I know that you're not
going to stand up yourselves Taco Bell
you you're too busy plotting your next
crystal nacht for the bowels so so don't
worry take it easy
we prepared a commercial to return fire
for you please enjoy hi with Taco Bell
you may know us from volcano nachos the
beefy Fritos burrito and that taco with
fried chicken for a shell take it from
us you don't want to run a healthcare
business like a Taco Bell no to be
honest you shouldn't really run a Taco
Bell like a Taco Bell oh because
we're nothing like dialysis clinics or a
start you may actually be more likely to
find a doctor in one of our restaurants
than in a dialysis clinic
can you burn my face sure and a
Crunchwrap yeah we can oh and look
we certainly made our fair share of
dubious claims
you know those breakfast burritos and
our ads this is what one actually looks
like gross but we sure as haven't
spent the last few years paying out
nearly a billion dollars to settle
lawsuits because we run a tight ship in
Taco Bell I lick the dust off the
Doritos taco shells they become a
regular taco shell okay the important
thing is our food maybe barely fit for
human consumption but at least our CEO
dresses in a suit like a human person
and he doesn't make it calling the mayor
do any that weird musketeer nonsense and
you know why we're a company what a
child's birthday party exactly and while
that food may be medically inadvisable
even we know that if you can you should
get a kidney transplant okay you know
yeah yeah you can absolutely get a
kidney transplant yeah no how'd you
get out here
Taco Bell Hey for once we're the good
guys here
[Applause]